what's up guys my name is Colin McNeill
for the score eSports oh my god we are
only a few days removed from a leagues
Boston major and the adrenaline still
hasn't worn off with cloud 9 making na
hopes and dreams come true there were so
many sick plays from this major to many
perhaps to narrow them down to 10 but we
did it anyway so buy up some Kevlar and
get your C's ed ready here are the top
10 best plays from elites Boston major
the first spot on our list goes to this
insane overtime round in the final map
of the grand finals cloud 9 is on match
point and rushing to glory mowing down
Kerrigan on their way to the B site but
when Nico is alive anything can happen
the Bosnian superstar hides in his own
smoke on banana letting the entire c9
squad rush past him with absolutely
godlike timing he exits the smoke on the
other side disposes of Russian and takes
control of the bomb saving phase from
certain defeat flashbangs and they start
pop star easy enough it will go in pasta
Nico but how many friends can he really
get that situation that's the fun he's
got that bond surely faze clan could
almost taste the grand finals up 15 7
against Navi in potentially the last map
of the semi-finals
despite the scoreline phase were not
taking any chances
outnumbered two to one Guardian pulls
off this disgusting clutch to send faze
clan to the finals and proves he's got
ice in his veins
to the final a guardian is an absolute
God that is so long way by Guardian two
back-to-back clutches that slope down
touch the phone thank him out nail the
shots and phaser go into the grand
finals after losing at their own nap
pick in the first game of the grand
finals
cloud9 took it to phase hard and fast in
their own backyard overpass with c9
already ahead skadoodle pulls off this
massive 3v1 clutch on the T side with
the bomb ticking away on be right so on
during the spraying I thought this good
food oh he's see the trick three he said
skate council was short he knows where
these players were he saw what a great
came from his teammate to tell him as
well he has 30 HP he's got no grenades
he's holding a slight angle guardian is
so red not expecting it it's good to do
let's watch butterfly do not fear for
Dylan
[Applause]
nerves of steel the silent assassin with
phase down nine five on Mirage during
the first map of the grand final the
tournament favorite showed why they're
one of the best teams in the world
facing down a five III situation
Guardian decides he's had enough
unleashing his four disgusting kills to
steal back the momentum what the hell
was that large oak from Guardian I told
you he is the problem cloud might have
to deal with in the first map of the
quarterfinals mousesports made it known
they wouldn't just fold to tournament
favorites faze clan with phase down 1514
on nuke Nico disposes of Chris Jane the
vents and finds himself in a 1v2 against
eco and sunny with the bomb down he
kills Sonny from long range then jumps
into incendiary fire quickly killing ste
coke before melting in the flames
himself pushing the game into overtime
hashtag just nuke okay world's best
player up against it to stay in the game
we're going along the time oh my god in
the flames as well during day four of
the new challenger stage space soldiers
were giving mell sports all they could
handle but stinko would have something
to say about that with both teams tied
1515 in the first round of overtime
decoe wins a sick one victory clutch on
the b bomb site up mirage with some
smart positioning and of course deadly
execution be holding an angle and there
was a smoke deployed or there was a gap
in it though he's got to go far so sick
he might have seen major major made his
way out holding an angle to go go
through the pre-fight smart stuff but he
is in a lot of trouble trying to buy
space for himself at the molotov think
you through it a bit too hard okay
maybe nervous I don't know space
soldiers they're lining up for M stick
oh look incredibly positioning smart
stuff great headshot spray is deke oh
that is absurd quantum Bellator fire you
may have been the Cinderella story of
the tournament but in their match
against G - Kenny s was looking to end
that story with the bomb ticking away
and finding himself in a 1v1 Kenny
Disney's Mantle's boom [ __ ] in a
surgical dance around the V site on cash
now this is counter strike up close
that's unbelievable that set the tone
for the rest of the gap in the fifth
round of overtime in the grand finals
there was only one man standing between
cloud nine and a major title
unfortunately for them that man was
Guardian with his back against the wall
at the B site he kills both automatic
and teurac in an insane - v1 that
frankly you should just not have won
sending the match to a second overtime
and saving phase from elimination
he's the only man standing between cloud
line and the major and
another thing clouds light don't do it
they're still in this phase of a plan
can't you believe it I can't even find
the words to describe this actually this
is just so incredible from both teams as
we've already seen there was no shortage
of nail-biting moments during that tense
double overtime grand finals third map
not the least of which was this crazy
ace by Taric to tie up the second
overtime for cloud nine the thoughts and
now they concede multiple anko territory
takes on a five sit down Dardenne on 11
HP reigns peaks and he gets the angle
now superior angle is there a diffuse
for the CT side the nor ninjas yet
describing the grenades they're touching
the pot and now go frame another bomb
that is trying to defuse a gentle no
guardian has taken down absolutely
unreal reserve line and the score is
tied
is it gone Olsen Manson was essentially
his cameraman in that position waiting
for the moment to actually trade but
Eric didn't even need the assistant this
is it guys our number one pick and what
else could it be
down 15 14 in the final map of the grand
finals Stewie to K decided to give the
hometown crowd something to scream about
single-handedly holding down the B site
against an onslaught of phase players
with his op he staved off defeat by
guaranteeing overtime for cloud 9 in a
clutch play that none of us will soon
for sure the Molotov comes in but so
does the rotation all of my snow has
been taken out towards beep on sight but
I was also Pathak's going towards a
nothing else is going on he's gonna go
back Stewie's on his own but look at a
time
we got a zipline science
[Applause]
they came back all the way
all the way
[Applause]
how fitting it is Stewie to save him the
only okay that was our list now you'll
notice a lot of our plays are from the
grand finals but can you blame us it was
so sick that being said if you can think
of some must include plays from a
league's Boston major that we didn't
have in our top ten holla at your
eSports dad in the comments below thanks
for watching if you want more great
content just like this be sure to hit
the subscribe button
[Music]